Maybe we've been drilling for the wrong thing.
The Iceland Deep Drilling Project bores holes up to three miles deep...
...in an attempt to make geothermal energy a more viable commodity.
But on a 2009 dig, the initiative struck magma just more than a mile down...
...where temperatures can reach as high as 1800 degrees Fahrenheit.
Several deep drilling reports in the journal Geothermics this month...
...suggest the accidental encounter with molten rock could be a breakthrough.
Engineers cemented a steel casing down the well, sending super hot steam up...
...and in the process blowing away the returns of other geothermal projects.
The well delivered moderate energy compared to other resources like coal...
...and had to be closed after a valve failed.
But its biggest achievement was demonstrating the potential for an untapped resource.
Iceland already gets a quarter of its power from geothermal sources...
...and this technology could one day become a huge export in renewable energy.